hi everyone welcome to the table my name
is Karen and we are live and I'm so glad
that you chose to join us tonight you do
not have to check anything at the
metaphorical door here at the table you
are fully welcome just as you are so I
hope you feel that even through a screen
as people are joining us online and by
the way make sure to comment down below
and let us know that you're here and
you're watching so that we can welcome
you personally but as people are
continuing to join us I want to share a
couple of announcements first I want to
do a shout out to our meetups a shout up
why not a shout it because their meetups
meetups are our small groups here at the
table and tonight I wanted to just give
a really really special word of
gratitude and thanks and shout out to
our meetup leaders we have Sarah John's
who leads our a lively book club that
meets meets once a month we have Don and
Marissa who lead our Rachel held Evans
searching for Sunday discussion group
that meets bi-weekly we have Darrell
that meet that heads up our men's
support group that meets weekly we have
the Maggie's Maggie Tilford and Maggie
Porter they lead the amazing teen girls
group and they and I said like I said
they meet weekly and then we have Brett
who leads the men's discipleship group
and yours truly and my husband Gary we
head up our racial awareness study group
as well as a brand new pandemic support
group those meet every other week so
thanks you guys for all the work you do
continuing to facilitate and lead during
this time you're so appreciated and for
those of you that are not part of the
meetup yet I would love for you to join
one as you just heard there are plenty
and there's always room for more so if
you're interested in
caring more about our meetups which by
the way are more accessible than ever
right now because they are all online so
they're very easy to join and check out
I just comment below or send us a
message at the table through Facebook or
Instagram secondly another just really
big heartfelt thank you to everyone who
is continuing to give financially to the
table during this time it's a really big
deal
especially right now we're a fairly new
church and I just want you guys to know
that it's so appreciated and helps us
continue to give to those who are in
need in our church family as well as in
our community so thank you for that
before we jump in I want to in the name
of shoutouts I guess my my whole spiel
tonight is about shoutouts I want to
give a shout out to everybody who is
working both behind the scenes on this
live stream as well as those you will
see face to face tonight so Josh can you
put up the the brady bunch of you then
there's Josh Rollins josh is our
producer tonight along with Gary they're
doing all the behind the scenes stuff
we've got Mindy and Maggie and Carter
doing worship which is going to be
beautiful and amazing and then Brett
giving our message tonight so hi guys
all right cool
thanks for joining us all right so how
about if we if we pray together so if
you'll close your eyes and bow your head
with me let's just take a moment to calm
our minds calm our breath Center on
Jesus
god we Center on you tonight we remember
that you are the god of generations that
you are faithful that you are good and
this week gosh women more than ever I'm
reminded of the power of words and the
way words have been used in the past and
gently and God I'm thinking of the word
liberation and freedom and how just this
week the word liberation has been used
in ways that are harmful and unsafe and
not for the greater good
and God I'm just reminded that we are
set free in Christ in order to
collectively help heal lift each other's
that lift others up especially the
vulnerable not to do harm to others God
so will you help us to just walk in that
and God when we're tempted to lead with
our ego help us to lead with empathy
when we're tempted to compare God help
us lead with compassion when we're
tempted towards judgment and scarcity
and looking out for number one god help
us to lead with justice and mercy and
generosity god that's who you call us to
be that is the way of Christ that is
true freedom where all can flourish and
thrive
so God empowers us to do that we can't
do that in our own strength so god I
pray that you would fill us with your
spirit encourage us empower us help us
to be bold and courageous in ways that
glorify you and love well and give hope
to others I thank you for this time
together God and I thank you for just
your goodness and your faithfulness that
spans generations in Jesus name Amen
Carter and over to you
[Music]
your low reaches to Hyrum your
faithfulness stretches to the sky your
righteousness it's like the mighty
mountains just this boat like the ocean
it's time I will lift my voice to
[Music]
worship you my I won't find my screen in
the shadows on me
[Music]
reaches to your face home and stretches
to the sky your righteousness it's like
the mighty mountain you just this boat
like the ocean inside I will lift my
voice to worship you my key fob Obama
strain in the shadows on go clean I will
live my boy to worship in my key
I will find my strength in the shadow of
[Music]
you lo Lord reaches to the millions who
now live my desperate solitude your
lungs all night shining in darkness so
tired and weary they find their way to
you and we will lift our voice to
worship you our key we won't find our
strength in the shadows on you bleep
[Music]
we will lift our voice to worship you
buy me more time house train in the
shadow on you lean on me when you're not
strong and I'll be your friend I'll help
you carry on won't be long I'm gonna
need somebody Nino this is a poem by
father Richard Hendrick he wrote it on
March 13 yes there is fear yes there is
isolation yes there is panic buying yes
there is sickness yes there is even
death but they say that in wuhan after
so many years of noise you can hear the
birds again they say that after just a
few weeks of quiet the sky is no longer
thick with fumes but blue and gray and
clear they say that in the streets of
Assisi people are singing to each other
across the empty squares keeping their
windows open so that those who are alone
may hear the sounds of family or
they say that a hotel in the west of
Ireland is offering free meals and
delivery to the housebound
today a young woman I know is busy
spreading flyers with her number through
the neighborhood so that the elderly may
have someone to call on today churches
synagogues mosques temples are all
preparing to welcome and shelter the
homeless the sick the weary all over the
world people are slowing down and
reflecting all over the world people are
looking at their neighbors in a new way
all over the world people are waking up
to a new reality to how big we really
are to how little control we really have
- what really matters - love so we pray
and we remember then yes there is fear
but there does not have to be hate yes
there is isolation but there does not
have to be loneliness yes there is panic
buying but there does not have to be
meanness yes there is sickness but there
does not have to be disease of the soul
and yes there is even death but there
can always be a rebirth of love so wake
to the choices you make as to how you
live now today breathe listen behind the
factory noises of your panic the birds
are singing again the sky is clearing
spring is coming
and we are always encompassed by love
open the windows of your soul and though
you might not be able to touch across
the empty square
I mean you live and that means without
say I am free
[Music]
[Applause]
you're
[Music]
I
[Applause]
[Music]
if you got for the soup that we have in
a love that rescues us from our myths
from our isolation from our loneliness
from our flesh God so grateful that your
love goes beyond my hands beyond my
mistakes and that no matter who I am or
what I've done or my life has looked
like in the past God and today's a new
opportunity to wake up and live
differently to breathe in grace to share
joy to be forgiveness and love to others
guide would you set us free from our own
ways guide and open our eyes to the ways
that you call us to a higher love and
deeper love a better love where we know
that we are now right where you have us
right inside your grace so thankful for
you are thankful for this community God
and what you're doing inside of us
continue your good work
[Music]
amen if you Maggie Mindy well welcome
everyone to the table grace in peace I
got to see some of the comments before
the service and it was just it was
amazing like - yeah just to connect in
the small way and I'm so glad that you
all are here with us and that we're not
just doing Church alone that'd be super
sad we had a live stream you know it's
on it so thank you
and do you feel free to comment
throughout the service and in my message
we love the you know engagement and yeah
it's a great thing so we must see and so
last week we took a week off from our
series in light of Good Friday and
Easter and we are though back to it this
week and so our series is titled
tranquility cultivating calm in a crazy
world and this message it really is one
that I believe it's just as timely you
know as ever in light of everything
going on of course with the virus and
such and so you know I think Justin let
there's just so much fear there's so
much uncertainty anxiety that haunts so
many of us you know right now and so I
think we're all kind of looking for that
that sense of tranquility that that
peace you know which is I chose that
word on purpose that is different than
happiness
I mean sometimes when people use the
word happiness they mean a sense of joy
a sense of peace you know calm
tranquility sometimes though happiness
can just be like just feeling good you
know so that's it's a little bit
different almost like a manic kind of
like that's different right the
tranquility because we can't live in
that place yeah that's different and
tranquility is this sort of no matter
what we're facing I'm rooted and
grounded in Christ in I know myself
there's a calm so that's that's what
we're going for in this series shrink
so with that in mind the title of my
message tonight is roller coasters and
mountain climbers and our primary text
is going to be from a book first John
chapter 2 and so John is he's one of the
twelve disciples and you might be
familiar with his his book the Gospel of
John that is a different book than this
one though of course it is the same
author this is a really small little
treatise it's only about like five
chapters long it's tough towards the
back of your New Testament if you're
actually looking this up in your Bible
many of you know you can read it on
screen as well either way it's great
and this book although it's small it is
a work of really I think unsurpassable
insight and beauty in many ways um so
John he writes these words to this
little church I'm probably in the city
of Ephesus which is in modern-day Turkey
and beginning in verse 15 chapter 2
verse 15 he says do not love the world
or anything in the world if anyone loves
the world love for the father that be
like God the Father is not in them for
everything in the world the lust of the
flesh the lust of the eyes in the pride
of life comes not from the father but
from the world verse 17 the world and
it's desires pass away but whoever does
the will of God lives forever
so back in February I was driving home
with a good friend of mine Lance
Westbrook some of you know Lance and
this was we were just taking a trip with
a few friends out to Burnett Texas
outside of Austin and so we're driving
back and there's something that I've
really been kind of thinking about for
years and then for some reason that
drive in particular I must have spent 30
minutes just looking out the window and
like tuning into this thing noticing it
and so suddenly I turned to Lance
and this by the way this is a classic
Brett Tilford Enneagram five moment like
you observe something for a long time
it's just kind of churning in your mind
and then suddenly you must blurt it out
at the most random times so I turn to
Lance and i blurt out I say let's have
you ever noticed how many businesses are
geared towards addiction see this is
what it's like to be my friend you never
know when I'll just run into the room
with like a quote you must listen to or
an idea you must cheer immediately like
right now I can be very rude about it
alright so Lance he looks over at me and
he goes what this is a very common
reaction to my outbursts it's a look
that says bro I'm totally lacking
context for what you just said but I was
undeterred I said just think about it
Lance I was very energetic just think
about it Lance like there's Starbucks
caffeine
there's fast food lots of fast food
carbs and sugar there's like vaping and
tobacco shops there's of course bars
there's all the fast fashion shopping
centers and then you've got donut shops
and peach' pizza joints and then you
have that temple of addiction known as
the gas station I mean just think about
it like you walk into a gas station and
there you have it all three aisles for
sugar her aisles for carb Alicia's boots
and then you have like your caffeine
wall and then your alcohol wall and then
your tobacco wall and then your gossip
magma and then your sexually explicit
magazine wall and then if you're like
really lucky this place will have a
dingy little slot machine so you know
you can gamble your last remaining
dollars while smoking eating a hotdog
and drinking your caffeine infused
monster energy drink so alright now it
wasn't quite like that's the same right
talk to Lance but you get the idea right
basically
I was naming that oh my gosh like I'm
some asking question are we arguably
like the most addicted culture that has
ever walked the face of the earth and I
think um this this idea of our the the
human dilemma of how prone we are to
addiction
John in the passage we just read I think
it's what he's naming he's saying there
there is this restlessness in us right
where we want we crave it's this
grasping grasping grasping nature in us
this is what versing verse 16 um
specifically I think is really zeroing
in on when it says for everything in the
world the lust of the flesh the lust of
the eyes the pride of life comes not
from the father but from the world all
right so what are these three key
phrases in verse 16 I think you probably
know them really well just from
experience
so first is the lust of the flesh this
would be like a craving for bodily
pleasure up in the Bible the the flesh
refers to like the body as opposed to
like the soul or the spirit so what is a
craving for bodily pleasure this would
be you know that that impulse for food
and not just like oh I'm hungry but that
kind of craving like oh sure I'm full
but I want more locked up or just where
we're sheltered in place right and the
food is always there it's so or that
impulse for drink um that bodily impulse
for like it's like sex right this would
be the the lust of the flesh usually we
hear that word lust we automatically
jump to like sexuality that's not quite
what the Bible always mean it's just
it's it names with that that crazy
inside of us right so let's the flesh
that craving for bodily pleasure the
other one it mentions a number to lest
of the eyes I think this would probably
be like a craving for possession so it
could be people right wouldn't we do
kind of lessen a sexual way with our
eyes like people possessed want to
possess them uh but it could also mean
like that longing for riches right
wealth we we we we sort of crave money
or it's often things money buys right
it's the things it's all the traps
well thinner I see those things and
we're like yes I want that I want that I
want that my son one of my kiddos when
my boys is very much in this stage I
don't know if it's a personality thing
or what but he just you know he wants a
Lamborghini you know and he sees the
things he watches the youtubes and then
sees all the fancy things like yes
a mansion Lamberty right it's the lust
of the eyes or third this one's a little
bit different but it says the pride of
life I think this is like a craving for
honor in social acceptance so that that
craving in us for applause for
promotions recognition positions power
now I do admit that that these passages
in particular can get kind of I don't
know what the term you've had badly
interpreted by churches and religious
communities of all sort of stripes you
know where they take these these
passages and then they begin to
emphasize that somehow these things all
of them in and of themselves are just
bad right so it becomes you know sex
equals bad you know alcohol bad enjoying
a cigar on the day your child is born
Eve but here's the distinction I want to
draw and this is based on a quote from a
Christian theologian and writer named
Dom Oliver Eddie Graham and I think he
draws a crucial a crucial distinction he
says this it is not what is craved the
delight the sensuous enjoyment that
causes trouble but the craving itself in
other words you know ain't nothing wrong
with a glass of wine with friends
or a cigar on a big day or you know sex
with your life part of your spouse what
what trips us up it's it's the craving
it's the addiction ain't nothing wrong
with a you know a Pringle potato carb
alicia's chip but it's the fact that
they bet you can't eat just one you're
familiar with the marketing right that's
literally what they say that you can he
just won and mostly they're right we
can't and kind of where I'm going with
this is here's eight a kind of a
definition of sin that I've been playing
with for a few years now and it's it led
to my outburst with Lance and I was like
oh my gosh think about a lens and I've
been thinking on this and it might be a
little too reductive like perhaps not
literally all sin is gonna capture under
this definition but I do think a lot of
it is and I think it helps unpack what
John is talking about in this passage so
here's kind of an idea what if sin um is
like addiction so or to put a bit
differently what if like sin / addiction
are the unhealthy ways that I ease my
emotional pain my stress my loneliness
my emptiness in other words what if sin
and addiction are my my short-sighted
attempts to create instant tranquility
in my life now why do I say
short-sighted because the activity that
I engage in it does in fact give me that
hit of happy chemicals in my brain right
so I get the spike I do in fact feel
release
I do feel even a certain tranquility but
a few things happen a it's very short
list right I don't I don't eat the
Pringles and be like oh well cool that's
my quota for the year I'm good I'm good
here no it's like I'm good for maybe
that evening if I'm lucky maybe an hour
usually an hour another like I hate them
for some more Pringles
all right so it's short-lived be it
actually drops my average level of
tranquility over time right
my kind of baseline of like I feel good
if you engage that addiction over and
over that baseline keeps right shrinking
and then see because of that shrinkage I
need ever more sin and addiction to give
me the good vibes because I'm getting
subtly less tranquil more depressed more
anxious over time this is what I call a
Doom loop Doom loops are sin loops they
are addictive loops they go something
like this so you have write negative
feelings so it could be stress like I
described it could be just that you know
general anxiety depression whatever got
the negative feelings that then leads
you to the addictive activity from that
if activity we find a certain temporary
relief but right remember the baseline
droppage we actually in the end though
because it's the hard spike then we have
the drop which leads to increased
negative feelings which leads us back to
the addictive activity which leads us
back to the temporary relief which then
drops our baseline right you can see
where this goes so I feel bad or sad or
mad or any is you're anxious and I just
can't face it I can't sit with it and so
I run from it I try to get away from it
via my addiction of chompy's I go
shopping or I binge Netflix or you know
drink too much or whatever it is for
each person and for the moment I feel
better all right ah sweet relief it's
sort of like um like scratching poison
ivy bless you if you're one of those
people that doesn't get poison ivy I'm
not that person I've had it many a time
and what happens with poison ivy like it
itches it's just like fire and you're
like haha
and so you scratch right and in while
you scratch it feels good but eventually
like you can't literally scratch it
forever and so you you stop um but then
in ten minutes or less it itches more
than ever right and so I hold off for a
while but of
chili I'm scratching again which then
leads it to burn more it's this it's
this Doom loop it's this addiction loop
a sin loop and I think the reason I want
to name this is because it is um I think
it gives us a fresh kind of insight into
sin that it's it's not always as simple
as you know like hey we'll just stop
doing bad things right I think it's
helpful to kind of understand why do we
go down these roads but having said that
I do think there's still a sense of
personal responsibility with even
addiction like when I think of addiction
I think of kind of along the lines of
habits like it's neither 100% I'm just a
victim of my addiction but nor is it oh
I'm just a rational human being and I
could choose not to do that but hmm I
think I'll choose to write it sort of
neither it's sort of this sort of messy
middle and that's sin right it's like on
the one hand I there is an element of
choice and yet also there is something
compulsive that grows over time right
and becomes stronger it's like I'm
dragged back to that thing now this can
brings us to our present moment like I
mentioned earlier we are quarantined we
are sheltered in place we are isolated
more so than perhaps we've ever been you
might be bored you might be out of work
or with you know less work which gave
you a sense of kind of meaning and
purpose and structure and all of a
sudden that's gone and so what begins to
knock at the door of our heart in mind
the Doom loop the sin loop the addiction
loop and what is it whispering is it
like is it saying rebel against God you
know become someone of pure selfishness
and hatred no no in a super twisted way
what is it whispering it's saying come
to me all you who are weary and heavy
burdened and I'll give you rest some of
you recognize that was this the words of
Jesus but as the scriptures say
sometimes the devil comes to us as an
angel of light in fact I think in our
addictions the devil always comes to us
as an angel of light offering us a
half-truth and it is a rest for 15
minutes but you might say that it that
it's that our addictions that are our
sin loops our doom loops are it's sort
of it's a rest
that leaves us in the end more tired
it's it's a tranquility that in the long
run leaves us weirdly less tranquil a
happiness leading to increased misery
now this III think I'm sort of preaching
to the choir here in ways right I doubt
there's a lot of you like I'm skeptical
oh no addiction that's not a big deal um
I think we did that this is this is very
pervasive a struggle for I'm not going
to say many of us all of us have some
kind of addictive thing we engage to
cope with our lives so that sort of begs
the question like what's what's the
answer what what do we do and I actually
think that that Jesus in just the
Christian tradition as a whole gifts a
really a beautiful answer but I want to
introduce it to you with a picture so
first I want you to envision someone on
a roller coaster and it helps of course
he's been on a roller coaster hope
hopefully you have but or at the very
least you've seen if you didn't have
enough courage to be on the roller
coaster do be seen right and there they
are they're for lying up and down and I
mean the look on their face like clearly
they're exhilarated
and it's exciting but if you're gonna
rollercoaster here's the truth you know
the highs never last never right don't
be fooled and that's the key right the
highs never last they're up and then
crashing down and the ride is always too
short because a human being cannot live
on a rollercoaster now I want you to
imagine the Rocky Mountains of Colorado
or whatever mountains maybe you prefer
whatever right and and now I want you to
like see the mountain and I want you to
zoom in and imagine a small group of
people um hiking up the mountain right
there on the path and they're just kind
of plodding along and as you watch them
uh it honestly doesn't feel like they're
getting anywhere very fast because you
know well they're walking up a mountain
but with every step they proceed towards
their goal right with every step they
are higher up the mountain that's the
key they are actually getting somewhere
now you're probably way ahead of me but
the roller coaster image is of course a
Doom loop of addiction I'm we come
zooming down all right more anxious more
depressed less resilient less tranquil
less peaceful than when we began
but the mountain climber is the person
who says I am going within I am taking
the journey of the heart I'm going to
seek that God I've come to know in Jesus
I'm going to face my demons I'm going to
have accountability in my life I'm going
to be a spiritual mountain climber and
it may be slow going especially at first
and some
it may feel like this is not working I'm
forever walking on this dumb path but
but there will be the occasional
clearing in the trees you ever had that
experience hiking you're like this this
terrible we're getting nowhere but then
suddenly the clearing the trees emerges
and you realize well maybe I'm getting
somewhere
and the longer you climb the stronger
you get the more of God's grace you
breathe in and then the faster you climb
in the more tranquil and resilient and
joyful you become now you say that
sounds great I want to be a spiritual
mountain climber how and that's a really
good question and honestly it's one that
I think the church has has in ways kind
of missed for the last few hundred years
actually ties back in with my message
last week where I talked about the
Enlightenment and how a few hundred
years ago there was this big movement
that really emphasized the human being
as a thinking thing and you know we kind
of from this there's a lot of good
things we have science scientific method
and certain philosophical movements and
all that which was great but it what we
kind of what we almost missed the human
being as you know we're not just brains
right we're we're emotional creatures
were feeling creatures and I think what
happened was because the Enlightenment
the church end up placing a lot of
emphasis in the last you know few
hundred years on study right you need to
study you need to you know read the
scriptures or memorize the scriptures or
do Bible studies and by the way I think
that's true but I just think it's a
piece of the puzzle all right you do
need to renew your mind you do need to
change your thinking get God's Word into
you right but that's only a piece of it
so this here's how I guess what I'm
suggesting is is I want to give you a
more holistic picture so here are kind
of two steps for becoming a spiritual
mountain climber for becoming
who's who's taking that inner journey
that journey of the heart away away from
addiction so step number one is pretty
obvious we've got to you've got to begin
reducing your addictions right these
what obviously as I said be the
unhealthy habits and coping mechanisms
that you used to avoid your pain your
discomfort the unhealthy ways you cope
with stress and so on and so forth now
perhaps you're thinking like I don't
know what mine are
why would just you think back to first
John like what are the things you do
compulsively what what are the things
that you can't control the things you
know you should do either like not at
all or in moderation but don't and
remember it's different for everyone
so for one person you know food is just
food for another food is how I deal with
my sadness from one person a whiskey is
just a whiskey for another it's how I
deal with my stress so that's the first
thing we've got to identify and then um
begin to kind of step back from reduce
those addictions this is where um having
community accountability in your life
can be really big whether it's attending
a a or like Karen talked about joining a
meet-up you know finding some
accountability and connection can be
really really huge as you begin to
reduce these addictions are accessed one
second and this is key and something
that people often miss like we often do
number one I gotta quit that but we
don't do number two which is replace
them with healthy spiritual practices
I'm gonna expand on this because it's
kind of more than you might think so
this does of course include the more
classic things and by the way these are
practices I believe you know all
Christians should incorporate in their
daily routines since they just they
beautifully powerfully connect us to God
and service foundation for other healthy
practices so that there's more classic
ones like of course prayer right whether
of like verbal prayer or just a silence
and meditation kind of prayer I'm
engaging Scripture right filling the
mind with truth of course I'm engaging
community like a
talked about like connection that's huge
but of course there are lots of other
healthy things we can do like I think of
the day you know spiritual growth
becoming a mountain climber like this is
not just about having a slot in the day
like oh it's my god slot it's about my
whole life becoming more healthy so
here's I'm just a lot of examples um you
could like it it looks like taking walks
um it looks like facetiming with friends
and family um journaling
reading books writing poetry going to
therapy engaging yoga playing sports
sports ball whatever kind of sports you
like working with your hands getting
outside listening to music playing music
cleaning your house working out I'm
writing drawing painting creating and of
course again the healthy things you do
those be specific to you and what is
healthy for you may not be for someone
else but in this time right you need to
start to identify what are your three
your five your 10 like healthy things
that bring you life and then especially
right now in this season were in engaged
them as many as you can each day and
even go further and actually replace the
unhealthy things you do with these
healthy spiritual practices now in
closing you might be wondering how
exactly does like stopping addictive you
know sinful Doom loop unhealthy things
and then replacing them with healthy
things you know how does this connect me
with God I mean like I know it should or
something but like how does this work
one of our favorite metaphors here the
table for this idea is is the language
of coming home um when I engage in
addiction I'm leaving my true self I I
am in a sense I'm leaving home I'm no
longer existing in love
and I I'm cut off I'm cutting myself off
from others I'm I'm no longer in loving
relationship with them and I'm I'm
distance distancing myself from God but
when I engage these healthy things in
healthy ways when I pray or go on a walk
and see the beauty around me when I
connect with a friend and share honestly
or experience peace and joy as I work in
the yard I'm coming home home to myself
home to others home to God so learning
to scale the the inner mountain of
myself and the deeper I go into myself
the more aware I become of the source of
all that is God Father Son Spirit
mystery of all mysteries source of me
and of you in the unending source of
tranquility itself we bow your heads and
close your eyes let me pray Lord we we
want to walk in freedom we want to be
set free we want to put away those
unhealthy things those doom loops in our
lives that that keep us far from you and
so I lift up all of my my brothers and
sisters watching and listening and I
pray that they would step away from
those things in their life that they
would they would make the decision today
to begin to let go of that thing and to
be begin to pursue a healthy whole
mature way of living and your word says
that who the Sun sets free is free and
deep and so we we named that God and and
I pray that would be true for every
person
thank you God for your goodness your
faithfulness the name of Christ I pray
amen
hey you guys we're gonna do one more
song together but before we start it I
wanted to read to you these lyrics that
I came across um if you want to go check
out after our service tonight a group
called common hymnal we you might be
familiar with some of their songs
because we do them when we're together
at the table but there's a new song that
they did called whiskey lows and I wish
we could do it for you tonight the
lyrics it's about an alcoholic and it
starts like this sometimes I don't feel
my highest it's like I reach up and find
that I'm not the tallest like my good
just ain't good enough
my honest ain't true enough and my world
is a sad kind of blue um and those
lyrics that I've just been listening to
it this week on and off and thinking of
this message on addiction I just love
how true it is that our addictions are
normally wrapped all up in in me and in
myself and what is wrong with me or what
I'm trying to cover up for and I just
want us to read this passage in light of
those lyrics this passage from Romans 8
this is the message translation and it
says but if God himself has taken up
residence in your life you can hardly be
thinking more of yourself than of him
for you who welcomed him in whom he
dwells even though you still experienced
all the limitations of sin you yourself
experience life on God's terms it stands
to reason doesn't it that if the alive
and present God who raised Jesus from
the dead moves into your life he'll do
the same thing in you that he did in
Jesus bringing you alive to himself when
God lives and breathes in you and he
does as surely as he did in Jesus you
are delivered from that dead life so
don't you see that we don't oh this old
do-it-yourself life one red cent there's
nothing in it for us nothing in them all
the best thing to do is give it a decent
burial and get on with your new life
God's Spirit beckons us there are things
to do and places to go
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
there is power to break every chain
break every chain break every chain to
break every chain break every chain
break every chain Jesus I just ask that
you would show us the areas in our life
[Music]
and would we trust in the power and the
love of Jesus that comes in and shows us
that rescues us on the pins this is our
feet on solid ground would you do that
unless even in unexpected ways in areas
where we have fought and fought and
fought would we experience new life and
new freedom God and would it push us to
love and to give generously when it push
us to fight for others and live a life
of sacrifice thank you Jesus thanks
Mindy and Maggie and thank you so much
for being with us tonight I hope this
time blessed you and reminded you that
you're not alone remember about our
meetups they're available for you
they're all online so they're super
accessible we all need a place like that
where we can be open and real and get
support together we're going to keep the
livestream going for a few more minutes
so please chime in and let us know that
you were here we want every voice to be
counted at the table you included so as
you go out from here into the coming
days let me send you off with this
benediction for a pandemic written by
Emily Swan I bless you with joy may you
find moments of laughter and bliss in
the midst of suffering and distress may
you cherish those times and may they
sustain you I bless you with the fruits
of humility may your humble and
sacrificial actions be instrumental in
preserving your community and loving
your neighbors I bless you with peace in
the face of financial hardship and
uncertainty may you know the faithful
presence of the God who provides go in
peace wash your hands open your heart
be a good neighbor you are loved we hope
to see you again next week
everyone love you guys have a good week
everyone bye